good morning John it's Thursday what am
I doing here this is now one of my days
I'm making two videos this week because
I want to explain something you may have
noticed you probably didn't but you
might have they were planning on having
the awesome socks Club window open for
two weeks and now we are into our third
week what is that about well we thought
that when we launched you would have the
ability to switch over from crew socks
which are like up to the calf and to
ankle socks which starting in January so
you could switch over and in January get
your first pair of ankle socks and
because technology is hard that wasn't
the case it's so hard just that one
feature has been quite a difficulty it
makes me feel like I would never pay a
lot of money to acquire a technology
company but if we closed it down it
would become very hard to switch people
over to the ankle socks so we kept it
open and now that feature is live and
you can go to awesomesocs.club and
there's a link and there's also a link
down in the description that you can go
to if you'd like to switch to ankle
socks starting in January you can't do
it before then because we won't have
ankle socks until January but now that
that feature is live it does mean that
the stock subscription window will close
on Monday the 21st so this is really
easier last week for real this time just
because there's been a bunch of people
who wanted to switch over and haven't
been able to I wanted to make a video
just like get that message out as far as
it could possibly get also really
excited about the light roast for the
coffee club that launched this week we
don't have decaf yet I'm a decaf Drinker
we're gonna get there turns out decaf is
surprisingly complicated and we want to
do it right that's like the whole thing
here the idea is that like we're working
hard to make sure that the the things we
make are like really high quality you
get to wear some art on your feet or you
get to have like the best coffee that
just tastes really good and is good for
the world and if we can't do decaf right
we're not going to do decaf until we can
and when we do I will tell you all all
about how decaf is made which is
fascinating and why it's so complicated
to do it well anyway just want to tell
you about the sock thing John you'll see
me tomorrow